MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we talk
about spacetime diagrams.
They turn out to be very
useful tools to describe
events or sequences of
events, in particular
when observed by
multiple observers.
So what is a spacetime diagram?
Here's an example.
You have an x-coordinate
and a t-coordinate
for space and time.
I plotted an event in blue here.
And the world line of events.
A world line is just a sequence
of events as they occur.
In this case,
something seemed to be
moving with constant velocity.
The world line is just a
continuous line of movement.
The velocity of
this event is delta
x over delta t, which
is 1 over the slope.
Let's have a look here.
So the time axis is defined
as those events which
all occur at the same
space, x equals 0,
whereas the x-axis is
defined as those events which
all occur simultaneously
at the same time.
And then you can
draw additional lines
into the spacetime diagram
where, for example, all times
are equal to 1.
You might want to add a unit.
I omitted this here.
Time might be given in seconds,
in days, in hours, in years--
whatever you like-- similar to
space in meters or light-years.
So lines here in green of
the same time, meaning time
is constant.
All events on that line
happen simultaneously,
while in blue are those
lines where events happened
at the same location, so
x is equal to constant
some specific values.
Here in red, I add one
additional caveat, which you're
typically not aware
or considering
very much in diagrams is
the role of tick marks.
Here in this spacetime
diagram, our tick marks
are perpendicular to the axis.
It's also OK or correct here
to say that they are parallel
to the second axis, and
we'll come back to this point
later on.
An example of a
world line is simply
drawing all events which
correspond to me, right?
Professor Klute is
pacing in his office.
You know, maybe on a line,
just the x-coordinate
is plotted here, time
passes, and I'm just pacing
the long-changing direction.
Each time, each little
segment is constant velocity.
That's the world line
of me from some time t
for minus t to term
time equals 40.
OK, so now our first
concept question.
Let's consider the set of
world lines, 1, 2, 3, 4,
and the question is,
which of the objects which
correspond to the world
line is moving the slowest?
Let's consider
this for a second,
and then we look at this.
As the velocity is
1 over the slope,
the object with
the steepest slope,
the largest value of the
slope, is moving the slowest.
And in this case,
it's object number 2.
All right, now we want to
actually make them useful.
Yes, they can be used in order
to describe certain event
lines, but they're
really useful when
you describe events happening
for different observer.
So in this activity, I invite
you to draw Bob's spacetime
diagram into Alice's, and
then as a second step,
draw Alice's spacetime
diagram into Bob's.
The situation is very similar
to previous ones discussed
in this lecture.
Alice is stationary
and Bob moving
in this rocket with a velocity
of half the speed of light,
or a gamma factor of 1.2.
All right, try.
Go ahead.
Try to show where is
the time axis for Bob
and where is the spatial
coordinate for Bob.
OK, so the way to approach
this is the following.
We want to use Lorentz
transformations in order
to figure out what is the value
of Bob's time axis and space
axis for different values of
Alice's spacetime diagram.
So we start with drawing
And then if you want to find
the x-axis as seen by Bob,
we have to set the time
for Bob to equal 0 and then
find the corresponding elements
or tick marks on the axis.
So the first point
we're going to find
is tB equals 0 and xB equal 1.
So with the Lorentz
transformation,
we find that xA 1, so
this point corresponds
in Alice's spacetime diagram
to xA equal gamma equal 1.2
and tA equal gamma times v
over C squared equal 0.6.
So we can make this--
find this first point and
plot it in our diagram.
It's right here.
OK, and then we go move around
and find the second point
and the third point,
and we do the same
for the time axis, where xB
is equal to 0 and tB equal 1,
then corresponds to 4.6
in xA 1 and 1.2 in xA 2,
where we find these points here.
I failed to say that the
origin of those two spacetime
diagrams [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
So this is already it.
So we found Bob's time axis,
where xB is equal to 0,
and Bob's x-axis,
where tB is equal to 0.
And I did draw those tick marks
parallel to the second axis.
So if I want to now find out
the time axis for xB equal 1,
I just have to follow along and
draw a parallel in the picture
here.
All right, so the
second question
then is, where Alice's axis
in Bob's spacetime diagram?
So the procedure is
very similar as before.
We draw Alice's axis--
sorry, we draw Bob's axis,
and we find Alice's x-axis
by setting tA equals 0, and then
we find the number of points
and connect those.
And the time axis is found
by setting xA equals 0
and finding them points
for various values of time.
And you see here, this looks a
little different than before.
I just zoom in
here a little bit.
What you find specifically,
because relative
the direction of motion
changes, the positive values of
x are in positive value--
and negative-- so the
positive values of the x-axis
are in the negative
time direction,
while the negative values of
x are in the positive time
direction, so would
be across down here.
So this needs a little
bit to get used to,
but you will later
see when I draw
in any of the two
spacetime diagrams
specific sequence of events,
I can immediately read off
how this event is perceived
from Bob's and from Alice's
perspective.
And this makes our space
diagram very, very useful tools.